every television series based in the
White House inevitably has to grapple
with one fundamental question what
motivates politicians and it's HBO's hit
comedy veep now entering a sixth season
that has actually figured that out are
you trying to blow up the universe now
almost two decades ago the West Wing
presented one answer in the form of
president Jed Bartlet whom creator Aaron
Sorkin imagined as a straight-talking
statesman and public servant who
transcends partisan politics and puts
the common good of the American people
above all else I'm the president of the
United States not the president the
people who agree with me by the way if
the left has a problem with that they
should vote for somebody else if the
West Wing is idealistic White House fan
fiction Netflix's breakout series house
of cards is its dark reflection the road
to power is paved with hypocrisy
and casualties house of cards imagines
the Washington DC in which corruption
and blackmail are the murky waters
politicians swim in this world only the
Predators survive and Frank Underwood
and his wife and co-conspirator Claire
devour anything in their path but it's
deep that actually gets American
politics right robots and torn up now
and America is wiping it nasty ass with
it it doesn't fantasize that politicians
are heroic figures nor the inverse that
they're inherently sinister monsters he
proposes something far more simple yet
radical politicians aren't special what
do you think dr Selina at this point I
guess what drives her is her own
narcissism I'm gonna go show everybody
myself okay okay let's go do it beep is
one of the greatest shows ever made
about American politics precisely
because it remains unsentimental and
neutral on the moral value of any one
set of political beliefs is there a pro
I don't give a [ __ ] Lobby yeah you're
looking at i had posters buttons not
really cuz i don't give a [ __ ]
and in the process reveals to us the
deeper universal truth about what's
wrong with washington base we're not
going to be dealing with face as an
issue in the th is bold but safe at the
same time they're nervous in space
there's nothing there it isn't that we
just haven't voted the right people in
or kept the wrong people out but that
our civic institutions are run by human
beings subject to the same psychological
forces good and bad that drive the rest
of us welcome after v president
president right and you never know some
days somebody might just political
theorists call this simple insight that
self-interest is the driving force of
politics public choice theory a theory
Nobel prize-winning economist James
Buchanan called politics without romance
public choice theory explains why we see
interest groups and lobbyists dominate
Washington despite their unpopularity
amongst the electorate why government
bureaucracies grow and grow despite and
sometimes because of a lack of
meaningful result it just might be why
the median income in Washington DC is
the highest in the nation and it's why
politicians sometimes
make decisions that aren't in the public
interest but in their own interests that
is so great for me and the country yeah
yeah yeah that's what i marrying we meet
all things that the show is about every
other politician but then that is 100%
true across the board in the world of
public choice theory it matters less
whether we get a Jed Bartlet or Selina
Meyer or even a Frank Underwood running
our civic institutions and more whether
those civic institutions are
sufficiently restrained by
constitutional safeguards and robust and
self-regulating enough to withstand the
inevitable human fallibility that will
constantly challenge and undermine their
mission that was a mistake or as James
Madison put it if men were angels no
government would be necessary if angels
were to govern men neither external or
internal controls on government would be
necessary beeps characters are neither
Angels nor demons but motivated by the
same mixture of self-interest and
self-image that motivates nearly
everyone and it's that tension that
makes it hilarious and true I mean at
the end of the day you know aren't we
just all finally just you know people
have two words ma'am the crying was very
authentic and humanizing I liked your
thinking I actually found a slightly
erotic to but kinda back
[Music]